THE WORLD OF FASHION ART AND
FOOD IN THE BIBLE.
BUT FIRST MY OPEN, THIS WEEK
HILLARY CLINTON SAID EUROPE
SHOWED NO LONGER OFFER REFUGE
AND SUPPORT TO MIGRANTS.
WHAT?
THE WOMAN EITHER HAD A
LOBOTOMY OR SHE HAS BEEN OUT
IN THE WOODS TOO LONG HER
LATEST FLIP-FLOP FROM THE LESS
GENERIC OPEN BORDER SANCTUARY
LET THEM IN POLICY IS A
STUNNING REVERSAL SHE EVEN
BREAKS WITH BARACK OBAMA WHO
SAID IT'S ABOUT THE CARAVAN
COMING TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> THEY ARE TELLING YOU AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO AMERICA
IS A BUNCH OF POOR REFUGEES.
.
>> NOW BARACK, I DON'T HAVE
TIME TO TALK YOU THROUGH THIS
BUT YOU ARE WRONG.
THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY?
THEY ARE HERE.
IN A MATTER OF WEEKS THEY ARE
HERE.
IT IS A MIRACLE OR COULD IT BE
THAT SOME ENTITIES PLANNED
LONG IN ADVANCE TO GET THEM TO
OUR BORDER?
BUT I DIGRESS.
BACK TO HILLARY.
WHY YOUR CHANGE?
HAVE YOU HAD A REVELATION LIKE
LOOKING AT THE UNITED STATES?
YOU NOW RECOGNIZE THE CARAVAN
MIGHT TO BE A TROJAN HORSE OF
CRIMINALS HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS, DRUG SMUGGLERS OR
COYOTES OR WORSE?
ALREADY THERE ALREADY 500
CRIMINALS IDENTIFIED IN THE
CARAVAN.
OR YOU ARE FED UP WITH THOSE
THAT ARROGANTLY DEMAND WITH NO
BASIS THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
COME HERE TO BE TREATED AS
AMERICANS.
OR OVER ELEMENTARY ECONOMICS
OR THE FINANCIAL BURDEN THEY
PUT ON THE SCHOOLS OR
HOSPITALS AND HOUSING AND
ENTITLEMENTS LIKE DISABILITY
AND MEDICAID?
NOT TO MENTION CRIMINAL
LAWYERS AND EVERYTHING TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM?
OR MAYBE THE FIRST GENERATION
IS A COMPLETE DRAIN ON HARD
EARNED DOLLARS ON TAXPAYING
AMERICANS.
IT CERTAINLY CANNOT BELIEVE
YOU ARE A RECENT DISCIPLE OF
LAW AND ORDER GIVEN YOU
SKIRTED SO MANY YOURSELF AS
WELL AS YOUR CLEAR DISDAIN FOR
TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
LEAVING THOSE LEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IF YOU DO HERE - - TO COME
HERE GET IN LINE LEGALLY?
OR MAYBE YOU HEARD FROM
FAMILIES AFTER THE
HELTER-SKELTER ADMISSION FROM
THOSE MS 13 MEMBERS FROM THE
LAST CARAVAN THAT PROUDLY
PROCLAIMED THEIR MEMBERSHIP
WHEN THEY ARRIVED AND THEN
WREAKED HAVOC ON THE INNOCENT
AMERICANS THEY MURDERED?
BECOMING A NATIONALIST
CARRYING FLAGS OF THEIR
COUNTRIES WHILE DEMANDING
ENTRY INTO OURS?
LIKE THE DEMONSTRATION ON THE
US-MEXICO BORDER WHERE THE
DEMONSTRATORS DEFIED OUR LAWS
SCREAMING FOR TRUMP TO LET
THEM IN.
IT IS FOR NONE OF THOSE
REASONS HILLARY SAYS EUROPE
SHOULD NO LONGER OFFER REFUGE
AND SUPPORT TO MIGRANTS
BECAUSE IT OPENS THE DOOR TO
POLITICAL TURMOIL.
SHE SAYS IT IS THE FLAME THAT
CAUSE POPULIST THOSE ON THE
RIGHT LIKE TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS AS WELL AS THE
BRITS THAT PUSH FOR TEETWELVE
IS TO RISE UP.
FORGET IT.
WE ARE LOSING ON THIS ISSUE SO
THROW THE IMMIGRANTS UNDER THE
BUS THAN HILLARY OPENS HER
SOUL WITH THE POLITICAL
ASSESSMENT OF THOSE ON THE
RIGHT THAT OPPOSE THE INVASION
OF THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO
FORCIBLY AND HER TO NOT BE
VETTED OR OFFERED NOTHING IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY GIVE TO ANY
COUNTRY AND DEMAND IMMEDIATE
ENTRY SHE SAYS RIGHT-WING
POPULIST IN THE WEST, YOU AND
ME, PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
POLITICAL YEARNING TO BE TOLD
WHAT TO DO WHERE TO GO AND HOW
TO LIVE WITH ONE VERSION OF
REALITY BUT WE ARE ALL STILL
STUPID AND DEPLORABLE.
SO THERE HAS BEEN NO
REVELATION.
SHE HAS NOT SEEN THE LIGHT.
IT IS PURE POLITICAL
CALCULUS.
MORE THAN A FLIP-FLOP IT IS
THE CLASSIC CLINTON TO STEP.
SHE WANTS TO BOOST HER BASE
SHE IS DESPERATE.
THERE IS EVEN TALK OF THE
2021.